[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a martial arts film called
fearless spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
[Music]
ten-year-old huo yuanjia is the son of a
martial arts master named endy and he
never allows hwo to take part in
training concerned about his asthma the
kid however has a passion for kung fu he
tries his best to sneak into his
father's classes to learn the bases of
it huo's only friend is a nerdy kid
named jinson he does all of hwo's
calligraphy homework allowing him to
train instead and he is the second best
in martial arts in their town which is
soon about to change because he has been
challenged by the best zhao huo is
excited about the fight and confident
that the victory will fall in his
father's lap and he has the upper hand
in the match and is about to land a
fatal blow on zhao but his beliefs and
fair gameplay stop him from doing so
taking advantage of the niceness zhao
retaliates and wins the match
dishonorably woe is heartbroken by the
incident zhao's son challenges him to a
fight when only the kids are together
huo confidently takes the challenge on
but is defeated in no time at this
moment he vows to restore his family's
name and become the best martial artist
in tianjin he and jinson go to his
father's library and steal his book
about martial arts then using the book
he trains day and night without rest
when hua finally thinks he is ready he
challenges zhao's son to a fight again
zhao accepts the challenge confidently
but is instantly proven weak against the
trained woe
several years later huo has grown up to
become even better in martial arts his
father passed away long ago along with
his wife who left him with a little
daughter quo spoils her since she is his
joy and pride in life since his last
fight with zhao kwo has remained
undefeated he has fought several
opponents but none of them were good
enough to give him a hard time huo has
also gathered a lot of fans and
followers over the years but along the
way he has developed pride and is
starting to forget his father's
principles he drinks and parties all the
time and lets his disciples focus on
having fun more than practicing some
days he drinks so much that he forgets
to return home to his daughter he has
spent all of his family's money and has
gone into debt but has no cares in the
world one evening he goes to his best
friend jinson who is now a wealthy
businessman and the owner of a famous
restaurant as usual fuo drinks until
midnight and treats his followers to
unlimited food jinson's assistant
reminds him that huo has not paid his
bills for over a year and they've been
piling up later that night jinson tries
putting some sense into huo jinson knows
that huo's disciples only like him
because he treats them to free food and
drinks he wants wove to be conscious of
his spending habits but whoa thinks
genson is just being stingy the
following day he bumps into his biggest
rival ken he is the only man who hasn't
fought with woe yet since he has also
defeated every opponent kin is
considered the best in martial arts by
many they get into a slight altercation
which hurts woe's pride he takes his
anger out on his disciples beating them
up while they train at night one of his
followers has to be brought to him in a
stretcher it turns out that ken beat him
up for some reason huo assumes that he
did it out of spite and is filled with
anger in jinson's restaurant ken and his
family are celebrating his birthday
suddenly huo barges in with his people
and starts drinking at a nearby table
ken asks him to put their rivalry aside
for the night because he doesn't want to
fight but foe is in no mood to back down
jinson also tries to stop him but is in
turn insulted in a fit of rage he breaks
up their lifelong friendship now even
angrier challenges kin to a fight and
asks him to kneel down if he doesn't
want to accept everyone gets out of
their restaurant for their safety
leaving the fighters alone they get into
an intense battle both matching in skill
and strength but when anger takes over
hwo he doesn't play fair he beats kin up
until he is exhausted and lands a
life-threatening punch on his chest it
causes him to die instantly huo returns
home in the morning to see his mother's
dead body on her bed kin's followers had
her killed to take revenge on him he
cries mourning her death before suddenly
realizing his daughter is also in the
house upon walking into her room he is
met with the biggest surprise of his
life she is lying on her bed covered in
blood in her hand is a little pouch that
she had promised to give him when he
returned home broken by the deaths he
has caused hwo steps out of the house
when his disciples inform him that the
man who was beaten up by kin had
insulted his wife kin did not beat him
up out of spite but for his wife's honor
filled with guilt regret and sorrow huo
doesn't see a reason for him to keep
living he boards the first ship and lies
down in a corner willing to go wherever
it takes him after living in the streets
for six months he tries to commit the
unthinkable but is soon saved by a group
of people by the river they bring him to
their tribe and take great care of him
but even after gaining consciousness hwo
goes into depression and doesn't talk to
anyone a blind woman named moon takes
care of him and is worried that he will
never get up from the bed her
experienced grandmother is confident
that he will be fine with time one day
moon feels foe's hair and offers to cut
it he walks for the first time in a
month and goes to a river with her where
she helps him cut his hair starting that
day he becomes a member of their
community he helps them cook farm and do
household work as a year passes moon and
huo start falling for each other then
one day a kid from their tribe is found
stealing a cow from their neighboring
community the grandmother and moon beg
for forgiveness from the rival leader
but according to their tradition someone
who makes a mistake should be beaten
until an incense burns out woe speaks up
for the tribe and offers to take the
beating in the kid's place for adults
the punishment is a bit different which
means woe will have to fight against the
leader although huo can finish him in no
time he doesn't want to use his
knowledge to hurt anyone anymore
initially he doesn't even defend himself
but after a little motivation from the
grandmother he starts to dodge the
attacks the incense burns off but the
leader is not able to land a single blow
on him he accepts his defeat and praises
woe the next day huo moon and the
children of the tribe are in the field
the children want to learn kung fu from
hua but he refuses to teach them he
knows what great power does to people
and wants the peaceful village to remain
as it is the children also innocently
mention that huo and moon are the
closest to each other but the adults
ignore the comment one day moon goes to
see her parents grave this reminds foe
of his parents and daughter who he
abandoned after her death now that he is
in a better mental condition he wants to
return home to visit their graves he
tells moon about the plan and she
happily encourages him huo promises to
return as soon as he can and asks her to
wait for him in the following scene we
see him enter his hometown tianjin which
is now an entirely different place after
the fall of the king dynasty several
strong nations attacked china and took
over tianjin became partially colonized
which caused several foreign residents
to reside in the city and influence
their culture huo goes to his childhood
house which is now an old shabby place
the family servant lyfu welcomes him in
he has tried his best to keep things as
they were but after huo's departure a
bunch of creditors flipped the entire
house to look for money huo goes to his
family's grave and apologizes to his
father he finally understands why he
didn't land the punch years ago when he
could have won the title of the best
player after that he goes to apologize
to key's family and bows down in front
of his shrine as he wanders around the
city he sees that a wrestler named
hercules o'brien is challenging chinese
people in a fight he has remained
undefeated in every fight and is
confident in the next victory to
conserve chinese heritage huo wants to
challenge him but he will need some
money for it for his next step he goes
to jensen's place and apologizes for
what happened years ago he promises to
have learned from his actions when
jinson finds out what he needs the money
for he doesn't waste time before handing
it to him through an assistant then in
the 1909 race club shanghai hercules
goes against woh at first glance someone
petite like woah could never beat
hercules who is double the size of him
before the match begins quo requests
that he and hercules fight with honor
and civility taking advantage of the
language barrier the announcer
mistranslates woe's request to he wants
to kick your butt making hercules laugh
the fight begins and huo instantly gains
the upper hand as the match gets intense
huo saves the opponent from being
impaled to nails on the side of the ring
as a good sportsman hercules accepts his
defeat making huo the victor huo gains
fame from the single fight and is called
to shanghai he meets jinson there who
proposes they form qin wu athletic
association a place where they teach
chinese students the art of kung fu that
way even with the constant foreign
pressure they can preserve their
heritage meanwhile a group of officials
from the foreign chamber is not fond of
huo's growing popularity among the
chinese public they fear that his wins
against the foreign fighters may trigger
anti-foreign sentiments among the
chinese people hence to make sure he
loses in the ring next time they propose
a match between huo and four foreign
champions consecutively in a single day
the japanese representative mr mita
promises to end hwo once and for all
this time even though the challenge is
difficult and is obviously a tactic to
make him lose huo agrees to take part
one day before the big fight he meets
his rival the japanese champion tanaka
they talk over tea and befriend each
other tanaka is a fair and respectable
sportsman like whoa but unlike the
people who are sponsoring him cut to the
day of the fight huo is made to go
against three fighters from around the
world but none of them last in the ring
for more than two minutes foe manages to
defeat all three without breaking a
sweat lastly he goes against tanaka who
apologizes for the unfair match and asks
him if they should reschedule hwo says
it's fine and the first round starts
they fight using weapons of their choice
huo uses a sanjigoo and tanaka uses a
katana amidst the intense battle they
accidentally exchange weapons tanaka is
not very good at handling asanjigu so to
make it a fair fight huo offers to
exchange the weapons again the first
round ends in a draw because of the hold
up while resting before the next round
khuo drinks tea that is poisoned by mr
mita who wants to see him lose one way
or another the round starts but woe
collapses and starts coughing blood
almost immediately tanaka demands that
the match be halted for the safety of
the fighter but when huo registers he
has been poisoned he wishes to continue
as he is going to die anyway even when
exhausted and seconds away from death
huoh manages to deliver a final blow to
tanaka's chest using the same technique
that killed kin however he holds the
punch back this time learning from his
mistakes but just then he collapses
tanaka declares foe the winner knowing
that he held back on the punch
deliberately in the end huo falls into
his friend's arms and dies tanaka
angrily belittles mr mita for resorting
to killing a man for the sake of his
pride he calls him a disgrace to japan
before storming off in the last scene
huo's spirit reaches the field outside
moon's house she runs to him sensing his
presence even though she is blind
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching